Ambassador John Bolton a frequent
fixture here on Fox was at the White
House yesterday for a personal meeting
with the president United States News
reports a lot of them suggest he could
be the next National Security Advisor so
the following question is more relevant
than out than ever what is ambassador
Bolton think is the greatest threat to
America today ambassador Bolton joins us
to me great to see ambassador glad to be
here so it feels like we're moving kind
of in slow motion toward a conflict with
Iran and Russia in Syria do you think we
are well I think that's one possibility
I think the Iranians have clearly gamed
what they plan to do after the defeat of
the Isis territorial Caliphate I think
they were thinking of it when our
strategist were not thinking of it and
we're now suffering the consequences
with Iran literally on Israel's border
flying drones into Israeli airspace I
don't think that's the really most
dangerous aspect of the Middle East
though I still think it's Iran's support
for terrorism and its continued effort
to get deliverable nuclear weapon right
so obviously Iran was greatly empowered
by the fall of Saddam I think we in
retrospect we can concede that there
haven't been any Iran sponsored terror
attacks in this country that I'm aware
of in the last 25 years there of course
been many many many sponsored by Saudi
Arabians of the Gulf states the Sunni
Arab world so why should we see Iran as
our primary threat because Iran for many
decades has been the world's central
banker of international terrorism
funding sHIIP Sunni terrorist on an
equal-opportunity basis providing arms
to them as they do to Hamas and the Gaza
Strip so it's their support for
terrorism generally that that should
concern is not necessarily specific
attacks in the United States but I mean
wouldn't I mean in order to you know
commit American troops and the billions
it takes to prosecute any kind of
conflict wouldn't you want to go after
the people who are attacking us here
first yeah well nobody's talking about
committing massive amounts of troops
what we have to worry about I think most
importantly is the threat of North
Korea's nuclear weapons program which is
more advanced than Iran's but it all
ties together in the Middle East you may
have seen reports recently of a UN
inspectors
study of North Korea selling chemical
weapons precursor chemicals and
equipment to manufacture chemical
weapons to Syria likely financed by Iran
so there's a palpable threat of weapons
of mass destruction something President
Trump
acted against earlier in his term that
the North Koreans have brought into the
Middle East with Iran's participation I
believe that they're all bad places
though in 2015 you wrote a piece for the
New York Times saying we ought to bomb
Iran in order to stop their weapons but
that's not quite what I said that's what
the New York Times headlines right well
I think how I read it anyway I mean that
as you know that they write the
headlines and the op-ed writer right but
I don't think it's the only time you
call for conflict armed conflict with
the run but if we had done that then
what do you think we'd be now well I
think Israel could have done it 15 years
before and we'd be in a much better
place as Israel itself and the United
States are in a better place today for
Israel having bombed Saddam Hussein's
nuclear reactor in 1981 and for Israel
having bombed the reactor that North
Korea was building in Syria in September
of 2007 so you've you've called for
regime change in Iraq Libya Iran and
Syria in the first two countries we've
had regime change and obviously it's
been I'd say a disaster I think now no I
don't agree with that and let me let me
don't think it's been a disaster no
because to argue that you have to argue
let's just take a rock to begin with you
have to argue that everything that
followed from the fall of Saddam Hussein
followed inevitably solely and
unalterably from the decision to
overthrow and that's simply not I would
never argue that I'm merely arguing the
map you have to sir since you well you
just said that Iran is the single
greatest threat to us into that region I
think you'll concede that Saddam was the
greatest counterbalance to Iran and they
were empowered by his by his fall so I
think it's fair to say if you think Iran
is the real threat that way you know you
just kind of hard to defend that
decision right no because I think your
analysis is simple-minded frankly okay
the Iranian threat which stems from the
Revolution of 1979 was under way quite
apart from what Saddam Hussein was doing
the Iranians have been tried
to get nuclear weapons for 25 you don't
think the saddam hussein's made a run
stronger i think it made the the fall of
Saddam no did not make Iran stronger
what made Iran stronger ultimately was
the withdrawal of American forces in
2011 so if you I mean I I'm not seeing
it the only person who thinks that
you're the only person I've met who
thinks that what would you say if you
could sum up the one lesson from what
has happened in Iraq what would it be
well I think the overthrow of Saddam
Hussein that military action was a
resounding success
I think the mistakes that were made
subsequently setting up the Coalition
Provisional Authority and others that
followed from it are lessons about what
to do after a regime is overthrown but
I'd also point out because of President
Bush's surge policy when his
administration ended stability had
returned to Iraq it was not a place
you'd go for vacation right but he
turned it over to Barack Obama and it
fell apart subsequently and the point I
think you need to understand yeah is
that life is complicated in the Middle
East and when you say well the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein was a mistake is
simplest I would argue that I'm the one
who understands how complicated is but
just my view it's it's your long
experience in foreign policy no better
record than yours I would say but thank
you ambassador good to see you